here is a little video I want to now get
us fully circled back to where we
started Vivek ramaswamy is running for
president he did this interview with
Tucker he's made the full announcement
and I'm going to show you a clip now of
gay Pete talking about what's going on
in Ohio and then vivec will be
commenting on it and I think you'll see
how we can we can actually change some
Minds by just clearly stating what the
truth is
look Rail City is something that uh that
has evolved a lot over the years but
there's clearly more that needs to be
done because while this uh horrible
situation has gotten a particularly high
amount of attention there are roughly 1
000 cases a year of a train derailing
particularly high amount of attention
because this happens two three times a
day the vacant I mean it's just it's
unbelievable that he said that out loud
this is appalling I mean look at what
the people in this town and this
community are going through and to be
able to be that callous to just turn
that into a statistic is just appalling
and says a lot about how the leadership
condescends on the people of this
country I'm talking to you from Ohio
today but on the other hand I've gone to
school at Harvard with people like Pete
Pete and I actually overlapped in
college and I will just tell you the
Dirty Little Secret is this okay people
in other parts of the country do not
take something like this as seriously
when it happens in flyover country like
Ohio if this had happened in New York
City or Washington DC this would be a
very different story in terms of
national media attention in terms of
attention from our government leaders
and the fact that he's even implying
that this has gotten too much attention
because it's just another statistic I
think reveals exactly why people in that
town of East Palestine do not trust the
leaders who are in charge because
they've been given no reason to trust
them and if it happened in New York
Buddha judge would have been there on
day one
you see why it's good that he's running
it does not matter whether you think he
can win or not getting someone who can
clearly articulate these ideas get out
there and stand up and and it was
freaking at Harvard while Pete was there
telling you this is how these people
think and we all know damn well if that
freaking disaster happened in New York
City or DC as they referenced Pete would
have been there in a minute he would
have got on his little bike and he would
have gotten there in a minute well he
would have gotten in the truck with the
bike and then a block out before the
cameras got there they would have put
him on the bike and he would have biked
over there with his little bike little
bike helmet and the whole thing
um
we have to do better and I think we can
do better and I think some good people
are getting involved and that that will
be our chance this is exactly how we
will shift gears people are wavering in
their support for Ukraine they're
endless support and it doesn't mean
they're Russian Stooges or mean or
selfish or anything else we care more
about Ohio I do period I care more about
the people of Ohio than I do about the
people of Ukraine okay this is our home
this is our country and and I'm just not
going to follow these war mongers on
their path to World War III
foreign
[Music]